numériser les skis après l'assemblée
nationale a également prévu de
s'exprimer demain lors d'un sommet
extraordinaire de l'otan consacrée à
l'invasion de l'ukraine un sommet auquel
le président américain joe biden a prévu
de participer en présentiel il a quitté
washington ce mercredi virginie herz
vous êtes toujours avec nous quels sont
les sujets qui devraient être abordés
demain on va parler sanctions
essentiellement sanctions
essentiellement effectivement mais déjà
le message c'est de montrer qu'il ya un
front uni au sein de l'otan face à
l'agresseur russe et ce malgré les
dissensions qui a pu y avoir à savoir
sur justement par exemple la livraison
d'avion les polonais avait fait cette
proposition finalement
les américains l'avaient bloqué au grand
soulagement de beaucoup d'autres on sait
que les ukrainiens aussi le président
volodymyr zelensky avait demandé la mise
en place d'une zone d'extension d'une
zone d'extension aérienne qui a été là
aussi refusé avec 10 dissensions entre
les différents alliés des différents
alliés qui par contre sont mis d'accord
sur la livraison de différents types
d'armes d'armes qu'on dit défensive des
missiles antimissiles essentiellement
une autre proposition est venue par
exemple aussi qui va être discutée sur
une force d'interposition de l'otan en
ukraine c'est une proposition polonaise
mais là aussi elle semble qu'elle sera
refusée donc finalement au final ce sera
moins sur des questions militaires que
des sur des questions et comme nos nuits
que les alliés vont en discuter et plus
globalement ensuite sur la stratégie
face aux russes et au renforcement de ce
qu'on appelle le front est de l'alliance
atlantique merci beaucoup virginie